a massive deal to combine two of the
world's biggest entertainment giants was
announced just moments ago the Walt
Disney Company is buying a large portion
of 21st Century Fox that includes its
movie and TV studios the hulu streaming
service and a number of hit franchises
the deal was announced this morning by
Disney CEO that's Bob Iger the expected
value is about 52 billion dollars
CBS News business analyst Jill suss
endures here's what that could mean for
Hollywood Jill good morning good morning
so this is a big big deal the numbers
are big some people have one perception
of Disney another of Fox so what's in it
for Disney so because there's so much
more to Fox and Fox News absolutely so
what Disney will get is the ownership of
the Fox TV studios the Fox movie studios
including those amazing brands like
avatar or x-men also gets an interest in
Hulu gets an interest in Sky TV the UK
version and you know also gets the
National Geographic Channel but as you
said very important here Fox will retain
the news network Fox News Channel Fox
Business News potentially folding it in
under the News Corp umbrella which owns
the Wall Street Journal so what does it
mean for the future Fox News and Fox
Sports well I think they're fine they're
gonna know what this deal is really
about is creating a ton of content let's
look at what the competition has done we
just look back 10 years ago these big
content creators didn't have a Netflix
didn't have Amazon now Apple you -
everyone's getting into the game whoever
has the most content regardless of how
it goes out whether it's a stream or on
broadcast those are the companies that
really are going to survive so last last
month we saw the Justice Department try
and block the AT&T Time Warner deal so
what about this deal I think this could
also it mean again if you use the exact
same philosophy which is we don't like
overlapping businesses or one company
controlling too much so the Justice
Department could come in and say well it
would likely let you do some parts of it
not all of it we'll have to see this is
going to be very interesting because
we're going to see more and more of
these combinations this is how big
content providers are going to actually
exist in the future they'll control more
and more stuff how it goes out is
actually less important Bob Iger just
recently said we're gonna stream it but
this is about content three four doesn't
mean for Hollywood Hollywood is gonna
have fewer studios but there's so many
different outlets that I think people
who are content providers will be very
happy about it overall thank you Joe
thank you so much